das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat
Beratungszeit angeordnet nicht einen
neuen Notartermin und deswegen
Beratungszeit heißt man berät über die
Sache genau dazu ist die Ampel
offensichtlich noch nicht bereit was ich
für einen erneuten Verfassungsverstoß
halte der ist ganz viel unklar also da
gibt es also ich könnte die ganze
Sendung Ihnen hier voll erzählen mit
Dingen die mir nicht klar
und ich finde ich bin doch gewählt
worden um sowas zu klären für die
BürgerInnen
aber ist das nicht bitter wenn sie
beraten ganz große Ernsthaftigkeit dran
wie ich gerade merke kriegen sie schon
dazu dass du daran
die werden aber nicht ändern
[Musik]